Good evening church.
Uh, my name's TR Lewis
and, uh, we're gonna study about the Trinity tonight.
It's a pleasure to be here with everybody.
This feels, uh, good. I was gone last week, so this is new.
It's not early set up for Good Friday, I'm told, but, um,
but we've got a condense thing, so if you guys wanna,
wanna move in close, uh,
whatever you wanna sit as comfortable.
I just got back last week, got back Monday from teaching,
um, HTI, teaching the, the Nicaragua HTI,
and, um, for those of you that don't know, HTI
as a Henderson Training Institute,
and, uh, started several years ago
with Wednesday night classes.
So Wednesday night classes to teach us as brothers
and sisters in Christ, uh, how
to study the Bible about church history, ecclesiology, um,
many different topics all across the spectrum.
And so the first class I ever took, uh,
and that was a biblical theology class taught
by Aaron Ferguson and Matt Felton.
And it was the first semester of HTI.
And, uh, to this day, um, is, is one of the,
the semesters probably that, that grew my faith
and the love for God's word the most in studying that.
And I remember that in the, uh, there's a book
that accomp accompanied
that class was called Dominion and Dynasty.
And I started reading that book,
and I got about halfway through the first chapter on Texted
Matt and I said, dude, I'm out.
I don't, I, I, this is hard, and these words are hard,
and like, I should need a dictionary to read a book.
And so he said, hang in, bear with me.
It's like, finish the chapter, go the second.
It's worth it, and it's good. And I did.
And it was, and, um,
and lessons from that class was still learned.
So we've continued that on that, that what
that happened is then about seven years ago,
that translated into, uh, a seminary style experience
for pastors and church leaders in Nicaragua.
And, um, and so this last week, this year,
just last week, we started our fourth round of students.
And so we've graduated three classes out.
So we've graduated somewhere around 80, I think,
or 90 students, somewhere in that.
And some have gone on to further admissions, training,
other experiences, but they've gone back
and taken back these lessons to their communities all
around northern Nicaragua and Southern Honduras.
So we started each class,
this is a long-winded introduction,
but we started each class last week,
each day last week we taught,
I taught through the New Testament.
So we studied Matthew through Revelation study,
the whole New Testament.
And, but we started each day praying for Henderson Hills,
praying for the elders, um, by name, praying for situations
and families in our church.
And, um, the pastors, the leaders, the the church members
that were there would stand and would pray
for us as a church.
And I told 'em, I knew that we were praying for them.
So I'd love to start tonight, um, by us standing
and praying together, and I'll lead us.
And, um, as I'm praying, if you feel called
to pray out loud, that's great.
If you want to pray silently, that's, uh, that's good too.
Um, two, two, uh, of the students that you can pray for.
And if we have time later, I can tell you the stories.
If you wanna talk later. One named Bayardo, uh, amazing man,
life transformed by Christ.
And, uh, pray for him as he goes back, there continues
to be attack and temptations that come on by Yardo.
Uh, he has an amazing story of transformation.
Number two is Roger. And Roger was probably the one of the,
um, youngest Christians probably in the class.
And I was going pretty quickly through material.
And Roger, I think at times got a little bit intimidated
by the other students
and pastors that had been doing this for a long time.
And so, uh, Roger needed the encouragement of the spirit.
And so if you'll pray for Roger for encouragement
and bayardo for perseverance,
father, we come to you tonight.
We thank you for, uh,
this time to come together as a church.
Lord, we know that you are in control of all things.
Uh, we give you praise for the way
that you've answered prayer through the,
the HTI in Nicaragua, the studies, the digging deeper
that we're doing here tonight.
Uh, father, we give you praise
for Pastor John's surgery going.
Well, I thank you that you were with him, uh, through that
and continue to do so through his recovery.
Father, we ask for Roger that you would continue
to encourage him as he studies your word, father
as he opens it, that his eyes will be illuminated
to the truths of who you are,
and that he would be encouraged to share
that with people around him.
Lord, lift up Bayardo.
Um, we know
that you have transformed his life in an amazing way.
And so I pray, father, that you would continue to refine
and strengthen him and make him a powerful, uh, testimony
of your spirit at work, in his community
and, um, in his region and, and all across the country.
Lord, tonight, as we, um, study more about who you are,
that your father, son,
and Spirit, three in one, um,
as we look at passages from your word
and how you've revealed that, um,
that you would enlighten our hearts
and our minds, help us to be fresh, help us Lord, to, um,
receive and to process Lord,
and help us to trust, uh, when we bump up against the end
of, of what our minds can comprehend,
that we'll trust you with the rest.
And it's in Jesus and we pray. Amen. Amen. Thank you guys.
Thank
Lest you think that the enemy is not at work.
He is. Um,
whenever we have things that the Lord has called us to do,
he throws, um, curve balls and, um,
but we don't have to worry about hitting those curve balls.
Isn't that a good truth? Um, the Lord goes before us.
He prepares the Lord, uh, has a plan and has a way.
And so it's good.
Tonight we're gonna talk about the Trinity.
I I bet most of you, uh, got to hear the sermon
and have thought well, about that, um, since that time.
And so what we're gonna do is, um,
is kind of dive back into some of that.
And, but also go, uh, dig deeper.
We're gonna go deeper into the Trinity, uh,
as it says up there and, um, and,
and unpack some Old Testament
scriptures that point us forward.
We're gonna look at, um, the persons of the father,
the person of the son, the person of the Spirit,
and how they come together as three in one,
how that's revealed in scripture.
And so, as I was preparing
and studying, um, one of the curve balls
that got thrown my way was
that our pilots decided it wasn't a good idea
to land in Oklahoma City on Sunday night.
And so we got to go back to Houston.
And so that gained me some more study
time and the Houston Airport.
And so praise God for that.
But one of the, um, one of the teachers
that I was reading from the Gospel Coalition, he said that,
that everything that you need
to understand the Trinity you have in your mind,
in your heart, in your experience, and in God's word.
And that, that, that we have what we need to understand
what God is revealing.
And, and God hasn't revealed everything about the Trinity,
and we can't understand everything about the Trinity,
but we've been given through the Holy Spirit
and through our mind and through our heart,
through God's Word, what we need to understand for today.
Okay? And so that was, that was an encouragement to me
because I think once we bump up against that, once we get
to the end of what we can understand
and we start to explain those mysteries, then
that's when we get into false teaching.
That's where we get into
to these faulty analogies that fall short.
And there's one, if there's one thing I love
to do, it's to make analogies.
And I'm forever in clinic when I'm talking
to patients about medical things, trying to describe it
to 'em as if it were a truck
or a tree or something like that.
And at some level, those all fall short.
And that's okay when you're talking about a, a broken leg.
But it's not okay when we're talking about the Trinity.
So rather than try to do that, um, and, and,
and try to find these things that are imperfect conclusions
or assumptions, we want to really, um,
be solid on the things that we can know.
And so that's what I wanna do.
And then remember that God is greater, he's higher,
and then we can have confidence in what we need to know.
There is one picture though, that I wanted to show tonight.
I think Neil may have it on a slide where Jonathan, um,
if we have it up there.
Yeah. So it's on the side.
And so this was, um, one picture that I,
that I came across that the more I kind of thought about it,
I really, really liked.
And, um, and I tried
to trace this one in particular is really nice.
'cause if you can, if you trace that with your finger,
it's all one line, right?
It's perfectly continuous.
Yet, there, there, it looks like there are a lot
of things going on, right?
There are a lot of shapes, there are a lot of things,
but really it's made up of three arcs.
So there are three arcs that make up that whole form,
but they're all one.
And you, you never get outside of that shape.
And yet you can experience all three arcs
and all three arcs interact,
and they actually make something more,
more beautiful than they would be if you just took
that one arc as a, in isolation.
But they're all together. So, and,
and that even this even falls short, right?
But, but as I looked at that, I think what you, you see
that probably on church letterhead and, and our brothers
and sisters in Loudoun County, Virginia, this is on their,
this is, uh, their church is logo Trinity Loudoun.
Um, but it was good, it was good for me to look at that.
So I, I may just leave that
up there tonight while I'm talking.
I don't have any other slides, um, to show.
But the truth is that God is one we serve
and are created by
and loved by one God
who has revealed himself to us
and to creation in three persons of Father, son, and Spirit.
And so we're gonna walk through that. Um, for those of you
who maybe didn't read the ene creed today, we're,
I'm gonna read that, uh, for you.
And it says, it says, we believe in one God,
the Father Almighty, maker of heaven
and earth, of all things visible
and invisible, one God.
And in one Lord Jesus Christ, the only sin
of God begotten from the Father,
before all ages, God from God, light from light, true God,
from true God begotten, not made
of the same essence as the Father.
Through him, all things were made
for us and for our salvation.
He came down from heaven, and he became
incarnate by the Holy Spirit.
And the Virgin Mary was made human.
He was crucified for us under Pontius Pilate.
He was suffered and was buried.
And on the third day, he rose again,
according to the scriptures.
He ascended it into heaven
and is seated at the right hand of the Father.
And he will come again with glory
to judge the living in the dead.
His kingdom will never end.
And we believe in the Holy Spirit,
the Lord, the giver of life.
He proceeds from the Father and the Son,
and with the Father and the Son.
He has worshiped and glorified.
He spoke through the prophets.
We believe in one holy, Catholic and apostolic church.
We affirm one baptism for the forgiveness of sins
and look forward to the resurrection of the dead
and the life of the world to come.
Amen. And so as we see that, we see truths of the,
of the Trinity unpacked.
And and there was another creed,
the ATAC creed that we studied.
And I may come back to that later,
but I want to have plenty of time for questions.
So I wanna jump through, uh, some of the verses that, um,
that, that open even in the Old Testament,
open our eyes to the Trinity.
But before even there, I wanted define some words.
So we talk about one, uh, essence and three persons.
We'll start with the persons.
And, um, one of the things I was studying from RC Spro,
he makes the point that language is dynamic.
And what we think of as a person today, uh,
is a little bit different and nuanced than the word person.
Even in the time of the writing of scripture,
or when a lot of the early church fathers were
writing out early doctrines of the Trinity,
when the creeds were being developed, when, um, tullian and,
and he was one of the early pers,
he's actually the first person to put the trinity,
the word trinity in writing.
And he defined it this way. He said, God is one substance
or essence, and God is three persons, um,
one essence, three persons.
And so we, if we look at that word, the word persona in,
in Latin or the,
or even in that time of like Greek dramas, they would use
that similar word to describe, um,
this is the way they described it, like the different masks
through which the, uh,
actors would portray different characters in a,
in a Greek drama, right?
So they would have a limited number of actors,
and there might be one actor
that would play different roles.
And so that actor would use a different voice,
a different persona, and have a different mask.
But it's the same, uh, actor behind all the different masks
portrayed in different ways.
And so that's, that's not a perfect way
to think about the Trinity, but that gives you some insight.
It's that outward expression,
that word persona gives a sense in that day
of the outward expression of a person.
Um, even a person's possessions would, would roll up into
that, into that idea.
And so that's the, that's a little bit of the entomology
around why we would say three persons.
It's three, three, um, revelations of,
of God, of our one God that he has three different persons
or, or personas.
It's the forward facing part, um,
would be another way to say that.
And then, um, the, the Greek word for essence would be,
uh, it kind of walks out
to the other word we use now for hypostasis.
Um, it's, I can't even say it, right, but it's UUs
or something like that in Latin, right?
But it's, it, it's the, it's the stuff.
I think that's of which something is made.
And so God is one, in essence, God is, um,
one in existence.
There is only one God, three persons.
And so that may not make it more clear, that make, it may,
may make it more confusing,
but we see God, um, in scripture singularly
and express plu.
And so there are different words even in the Old Testament.
So the word Yahweh, um, that is, is kind of that word that,
that we've kind of created Yahweh out of four letters
that you can't even really say, uh, the name of God
that way, but we've kind of created a Yahweh in the English.
But that's a singular, right?
That's a singular expression of our one God in essence
that we are, we, we believe in one true God.
And then there are times in scripture, like in Genesis one,
where the word elim is used,
and elim is actually a, a plural word in Hebrew.
And so there's a plural expression of a, of a,
of our triune God, of the three persons
together in relationship.
Um, one of the other ones that I came across, another word
that was good for me to understand,
because many people, um, that would try to deny the,
the three and just say, God is one,
we'll focus on Deuteronomy six.
And in Deuteronomy six it says, the Lord
of God, the Lord is one.
And that word one is ihad,
or I think is how you pronounce it, but it's, it's EHAD.
And the, and that's the type of one that means united.
It's a, it's a, it gives a sense of one
and unity, that word.
And so it's actually the same word
that's used in Genesis 2 24 to understand what it means
for a man and woman to become one, to come together
as one flesh, that same word, iad of a perf of a,
a perfect in just 2 24.
It's joining together. Um,
but as we talk about, uh, God, it's an essence
and perfect, uh, perfect, um, existence.
Um, the next is Adonai.
That's another word we see in scripture that we, um,
sometimes think about.
And seeing Adonai is actually a plural word.
It's a plural for addon, which means Lord or master.
So we even see that's a, a plural, like expressing God, uh,
as three, but three in one.
And it's views sometimes as a substitute for Yahweh
as writers would be even, uh, feel a sense of irreverence
to write out Yahweh.
And so they would, they would substitute in Denai, um,
throughout the Old Testament, it will start
to pit into some of the scriptures.
But we see, we see God the Father expressed,
and we see God, uh, the Father all over.
We see different manifestations of what are called
Theos or Christoph.
And I was, as I was studying back through this,
I was remembering, I think the first time I was exposed to
that was in that biblical theology
class as we walked through that.
And so the, the phrase used in many Old Testament scriptures
is angel of the Lord.
And so we see the angel of the Lord, uh, relating
and talking as a person, um, about
himself, about the trinity and with others.
And so, um, there's a few, uh, we're gonna, I'm gonna go
through a few passages.
The first is, uh, if you flip Genesis 22,
I put my bookmark in Nehemiah in case I had a hard time
finding Nehemiah, so I'm gonna leave it there.
But Genesis 22, if you guys turn to Genesis 22, chapter 12,
we're gonna see, uh, this is Abraham.
And so Abraham, um, had, has his son Isaac.
So Isaac is the promised son,
and he's been commanded to take Isaac up to build an altar
and then to sacrifice Isaac on that altar.
And so they take up wood, they take up what they need,
but they don't take up any sacrifice,
and they're on the mountain.
And then you guys, many would know that the Lord
provided a ram in the thicket.
And then in, um, back in chapter 12, uh,
Abraham has raised his knife and,
and then says, the angel of the Lord called
to him in verse 11 and said, Abraham, Abraham, here I am.
And he said, do not lay your hand on the boy
or do anything to him for now I know that you fear God
and see, you have not withheld your son,
your only son from me.
And so there's this, there's this sense
that he's talking about that you fear God
and you haven't, he's identifying himself as God,
this angel of the Lord.
So it's a, it's a, it's a manifestation
of, of God the Father.
Um, we think of Theophany in this case, um,
identifying himself as you've got withheld your son from me.
And so we see, uh, that again in Exodus three, chapter two
when, um, when Moses is, uh,
called to the burning bush.
And so we see that, um, he, uh, approaches with his,
uh, chacos on, and he said, don't do that.
You're on holy ground.
And this is the angel of the Lord appeared
to him in a flame out of the midst of the bush.
And he looked and behold the bush was burning,
yet it was not consumed.
And, and Moses said, I'll turn aside to this great sight.
Why is the bush not burned?
And when the Lord saw, he turned aside, and,
and God called to him out of the bush.
And so we see this angel of the Lord identified as God.
And so there's, there's many passages throughout, um,
throughout judges, which I thought was interesting,
where this angel of the Lord
appears to the different people.
And one is when, when Gideon, uh, was called,
and it says that the angel of the Lord.
And he calls back out to him, oh Lord God,
he identifies him as God.
And at the end of that passage, he says, be basically,
be secure, be strong, because I am with you.
It's that person, that expression of God,
that personal expression of God.
We see it as Samson's, uh,
mother also has receives a similar message.
And so we'd see these interpersonal, uh, relationships
of God, uh, in, uh, through his
persona with his people, um, as we move to kind of evidences
or manifestations seeing the Holy Spirit
in scripture in the Old Testament.
Let's flip over to Nehemiah.
Um, if you have a journaling Bible, it's on page 4 0 4.
If you don't, uh, then, then you'll be able
to find it 'cause it's right after Ezra.
But, um, in verse in, in Nehemiah chapter nine,
that the, the people of Israel are confessing.
They're confessing all that they've done.
And then, um, they speak
about the spirit of the Lord.
So if we're in, if, if you found Nehemiah nine, go
to verse 20 and it says, you gave your good spirit
to instruct them and did not withhold your manna from their
mouth and gave them water for their thirst
for 40 years, you sustain them in the
wilderness and they lack nothing.
Their clothes did not wear out,
and their feet did not swell.
And so they're, they're talking to, to God that,
that they, his, the Holy Spirit was given,
but also that God the Father was providing from heaven.
And then we see in verse 30 says, many years you bore
with them and warn them then through your spirit
and then through your prophets,
yet they would not give your,
therefore you gave them into the hand
of the peoples of the lands.
And so that he's, he's warning 'em through the spirit,
then speaking through prophets.
So we see this spirit speaking through prophets.
And last week in Nicaragua,
we were just studying about when the verses we kicked off
the week was two Peter chapter one, right, that no,
no prophecy was brought forth
by man, but it was carried forth.
They were carried forth by the Holy Spirit,
that the Holy Spirit speaks through the prophets,
through the, he spoke through the prophets of old to, uh,
to reveal scripture.
And, um, and then in this passage of ne miah
to warn the people, um, what's to come.
So we see the, the father
and the spirit working in conjunction, um,
in these passages in a in a related sense.
Let's flip over next to Isaiah. This is a lot of scripture.
We're gonna get to questions here in a little bit,
and I think that's gonna be, uh, super fun.
And we're gonna fill this chair when that happens.
But, um, let's jump into Isaiah chapter 48.
So flip over real quick.
I'll give you a minute to turn there.
And this is the Lord's call to Israel.
And so we see, we see evidence of, of the trinity,
of different persons of God express as we read through, um,
verses 12 through 17, but wants to stop and,
and pause a little bit on 16, I'm gonna start in 12.
He says, listen to me, o Jacob
and Israel, whom I've called, I am He, I am the first
and I'm the last.
My hand laid the foundation of the earth
and my right hand spread out the heavens when I call
to them, they stand together, assemble all of you,
and listen, who among them has declared these things?
The Lord loves him. He shall perform his purpose on Babylon.
His arms shall be against the Chaldeans.
I even, I have spoken and called him and have brought him,
and he will prosper in his way.
Listen to 16, draw near to me.
Hear this from the beginning.
I have not spoken in secret from the time it came to be.
I have been there. And now the Lord God has sent
me and his spirit.
So right there at the end of Isaiah 48, 16,
we see the three persons of God.
We see the Father sending the Son
and sending the Spirit to proclaim the things
that we would say have been proclaimed in secret.
But he says that they have been spoken, um, not in secret.
And then he says, thus says the Lord, your redeemer,
the holy one of Israel, I'm the Lord your God,
who teaches you to profit,
who leads you in the way you should go.
And so the Lord, he reveals himself for our good.
He reveals himself in these three different ways,
because number one, that's who he is.
And so we, we relate to the Father
and the Son, the Spirit, um, all one.
But, but all, uh, we, we relate differently, uh,
to the different persons of that.
And it's a, it's a beautiful, it's a mystery.
And so several people that I was talking, uh,
I was listening to speak,
but also reading, we're talking about the difference
between a controversy and a mystery, right?
And a controversy is like, we're we're upset about it.
And there's, there's a controversy because something's right
and something's not and, and what's right and what's not.
And there are, there are, um, cults
and there are false teachers and,
and false religions that have heretical beliefs
that would make a controversy about the Trinity.
But really, it's a beautiful mystery.
It's, it's, it's a, it's the, it's a magnificent way
that God is, he is a being.
He is he, he is one,
and yet he is three persons in one.
And so, um, it, it's not, it's a, it's a mystery
because we can't fully understand the side
of heaven how that is.
But it's beautiful in that he's revealed
to us what we can know.
And, and we just can study and study and study.
So, um, while we're still here in Isaiah,
I wanna flip over to chapter 55.
'cause there's another, uh, I'm sorry, chapter 45,
I misspoke Chapter 45 in Isaiah.
And this is a, this is one where, so in chapter 40, uh,
eight, we saw the three persons of God,
and then we were brought back to this unity, uh,
or in, in Isaiah 45.
And this is, uh, this is actually a verse that, um,
that some controversy, promoters
or, uh, Trinity opposers would, um, would bring up.
And so verses five through seven, it says,
someone would say in scripture, it says, I'm the Lord
and there is no other besides me.
There is no God. I equip you though you do not know me,
that people may know.
And from the rising of the sun from the west,
that there is none besides me.
I'm the Lord, and there is no other.
I form light and create darkness.
I make wellbeing and create calamity.
I am the Lord who does all these things.
And so they would say, it says right there in your Bible,
in your scripture, that besides me, there is no other God.
I'm the Lord, and there is no other. And we would say, amen.
That's right. He is the God. He is one. There is no other.
There is no other God who is one in essence
and three in person, right?
There is no other God who is one that we can trust, that,
that loves us, has poured himself out for us.
And so, um, to say God is one, yes, amen. That is true.
But it, but then we unpack that to understand the Trinity.
Um, one other thing we've got in Old Testament scriptures
of the use of plural pronouns.
And so, um, there are, there are scriptures, Genesis 1 26,
where he says, let us make man in our own image,
I mean in our likeness.
And so, so we see that God as he's expressing, as we're
to let us make man in our image
after our likeness, so that we would be made in the image
of our triune God at the time of the fall, we see God say,
behold man has become like one of us, knowing good and evil.
And then later in Genesis 11, at the Tower of Babel,
God says, let us go down there
and confuse their language, father, son
and spirit to earth to do that.
And then in, in one passage that we,
that we celebrate in Isaiah chapter six,
where Isaiah's in the temple
and he sees the glory of the, of the majesty of God,
fill, fill that space.
And then the Lord says, whom shall I send?
Who will go for us?
So even in that passage, you see the singular
personal pronoun, I, whom shall I send?
And in the very second half of
that sentence, who will go for us?
And so God's given us these glimpses. It's not a secret.
Um, it's just reliant upon us to,
to unpack and then to trust.
We see, uh, other Messianic references throughout Psalms.
One of the famous ones is in, uh, Psalms 110.
And in, um, Psalms 110 verse one,
we see this interpersonal relationship play out
where he says, the Lord says, to my Lord,
sit at my right hand
until I make your enemies your footstool.
The Lord sends forth from Zion your mighty scepter
rule in the midst of your enemies.
And that scepter that he references there is,
is a reference back to, um, it's a reference back
to Genesis chapter 49, when Jacob's laying out the blessing
and the promises for all of his sons, right?
He goes one by one.
And when he lands on Judah, he talks about the lion,
but he also talks, the scepter talks about
the scepter going up from Judah.
So when you see the word scepter, again, this is a, an old
biblical theology, HTI lesson from, uh, professor Ferguson,
that when you see that scepter come out, that's Christ.
That's the promise of our redeemer.
That's the promise of the king coming through.
We see it come out at different places in scripture,
but it started, it has its root in Genesis 49.
So in Psalm one 10, then we see the Lord
Father on the throne says to my Lord the king, the son
of David, the son of man, Jesus Christ,
to sit at my right hand.
So we see the Father and the Son together.
We also see in Psalm chapter 45,
if we flip over there, this is a whole psalm
that has sung to the king.
And in verses six
and seven, we see the words,
your throne over God is forever and ever.
The scepter of your kingdom is a scepter of, of uprightness.
You have loved righteousness and you have hated wickedness.
And so it says,
therefore, your God has anointed you with the oil
of gladness beyond your companions.
And so he's saying that you are you Christ, you Jesus,
you the Son, are on the throne,
and your God has anointed you.
And so that God the Father, so there's this, he's the,
the psalmist is unpacking this in Psalm,
this beautiful relationship between the Father and the Son.
And then in Isaiah chapter 61, this is the last of the kind
of plural pronoun, uh, I'm sorry, the last
of the Messianic reference passages.
There are many more,
but this is the last one we'll study tonight in chapter, uh,
61 of Isaiah, verse 61, we see the spirit
and he says, the spirit of the Lord God is upon me
because the Lord has anointed me
to bring good news to the poor.
And he has sent me to bind up the broken hearted,
to proclaim liberty to the captives, the opening
of the prison, to those who are bound to proclaim the year
of the Lord's favor,
and the day of vengeance from our God to comfort all
who mourn, to grant to those who mourn in Zion,
to give them a beautiful headdress instead of ashes, oil
of gladness instead of mourning.
And so we see that this is a, this is a, a passage
where Isaiah's prophesying of the coming Christ
and all the things that we will,
that we'll do, that he will do.
And it says, the spirit of the Lord came
upon me to tell me this.
And so we see father sin
and spirit again at work in Isaiah chapter 61,
um, there's two other pa Old Testament passages I wanna
finish with, and then we'll, we'll jump ahead.
But in, uh, in back in Isaiah chapter six again, it, it,
we we're back in that, in that, uh, situation in the temple.
And, um, and you remember the praise,
it was holy, holy, holy.
And we see that represented three times.
So there's a sense of threes.
There's that holiness that said three times, holy, holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty.
And that's true, because God, the Father is holy
and God, the Son is holy, and God, the Spirit is holy.
And as you read and study through that, um, um,
antonian creed, you see that that reference,
that refrain play out the other part.
The other verse I came across I thought was really neat was
one that I love, it's numbers chapter six,
verses 24 through 26.
And, and it's this, um, it's this blessing.
It's kind of this, um, this send out, right?
The, the, that the Lord would bless you and keep you.
The Lord was make his face to shine upon you, the Lord.
Um, let me read it.
I'm trying to recite it while I'm getting there.
I'm gonna mess up turning pages.
But it would say, the Lord bless you
and keep you, the Lord make his face to shine upon you
and be gracious to you.
The Lord defend his countenance upon you and give you peace.
And so we see the Lord referenced three times in that,
and that the Lord is, is revealing himself in, in three kind
of little bit different ways, that the Lord would bless you,
the Lord would make his face to shine upon you,
and then the Lord would give his countenance,
which is his face again, that he's poured out to us.
But that would bring us peace, that the,
maybe the graciousness of Christ comes through that,
and then through the Spirit,
his countenance would give us peace.
And so we see that, that the Trinity even expressed in
that blessing in the book of numbers.
Um, so many people try to pull out, uh,
passages from the Old Testament
and say, no, it's, it's, it's, it's only one.
It's not three. And so just as we answer
to Isaiah chapter 48, we can also answer
to Isaiah chapter 44
and 46, that there is no other God.
That's what that's proclaiming into that we would say yes.
Um, so as I was studying
and looking back through the, the different New Testament
passages that, that John shared, and in one Corinthians 12
and Galatians, that, that we trust the way
that God has revealed himself, that he has
revealed himself perfectly.
Um, we see in, in John chapter five verse 30, this,
um, passage where that Christ came to do, he says, the will
of the one who sent me,
and he, I came not on my own authority,
but on the authority of the one who sent me.
And, and many people will, will, will use that passage
to say that then Jesus isn't God
or he's, he's someone not equal with God.
And, and really what he's displaying is the Philippians
chapter two, humility of Christ.
Jesus is displaying whose humility in that moment
because we know from Philippians that,
that he was created perfectly in God image.
And in Colossians, we see that he's the perfect, uh, imprint
of his likeness, but that he did, he, he, he made himself,
he humbled himself, um, taking on the flesh
to come to this earth.
And so, um, as we walked through all these passages,
we would just say that the,
the Trinity is not something concocted by, um,
by the Roman Catholic Church
or by, um, people after the fact.
It's, it's all over scripture.
It's all throughout scripture.
From Genesis all the way to Revelation, we see the Father
and the Son and the Spirit all interacting together.
We even see that in, um, in the first two chapters
of Revelation, uh, revelation six, where there's the glory
and the worship around the throne,
and we see, uh, the image of the Father on the throne.
We see the image of the Son
and the image of the Spirit as, uh, as flames surrounding
that all giving glory, uh, in that place.
So we see it from Genesis to Revelation.
And so, um, the pillars that we would walk away from, um,
would be that yes, uh, we are monotheists.
We believe in one God, we believe in one God, um,
the creator of heaven and earth, and that there is no God
before him, and there's no God like him,
and there will be no God after him.
We believe in the God of Deuteronomy six.
And um, and we love him and we adore him.
Uh, we believe in the one God of Isaiah chapter 44 and 45,
and that we would, um, turn to him
and be saved like it says there.
And we, we believe that our God is three in one. Okay?
And so I was, I was writing that out.
I think we talked some about that.
He's not like the, the different analogies on Sunday.
It's not three different parts that all come together.
She can't take one part out.
And so in East Texas, instead of saying three in one,
we would say three in one.
You know, it's like with just the
letter n with a little apostrophe.
And so maybe that's how we think about,
it's like three in one.
Um, and so these, he's not three gods, but he's one God.
And, and really, um, we, we talked,
we studied about the Trinity several months ago,
not the Trinity, the Holy Spirit
and Pentecost, um, back last spring.
And we talked about who is the Holy Spirit.
And so we, we would think about the who of the persons,
and then the what of the essence.
So we would say that we have one what?
And that one, what is God?
Uh, in three person who are three, we have three who's so
to speak, um,
talk about the Father manifest in the Holy Spirit in, um,
first Peter chapter one, verse two.
He talks about God the Father very clearly on display.
And then, um, in Matthew chapter three,
we see this interaction.
This is, um, I think, uh,
John referenced Mark chapter one in Matthew chapter three,
we see the same, uh, the same story play out
of Jesus' baptism.
So we, it's, we see the, the Holy Spirit, the Trinity,
the Father and the, and the Son all come together
at Jesus's baptism.
So let's read a couple verses from that so we can kind of
see all that, um, together and just be reminded.
It says, um, in Matthew chapter three, see,
most people have to put on glasses when they read.
I have to take mine off. It's a different type of,
um, aging.
It says. And when Jesus was baptized,
he immediately went up from the water,
and behold the heavens were open to him,
and he saw the spirit of God descending like a dove
and coming to rest on him.
And he's the son. And behold, there was a voice from heaven
that said, this is my beloved son, with whom I'm well
pleased, that God the father, blessed
God, the Father identified the Son
and sent his spirit as a, as a physical expression
that this descending on him while like a dove.
In that moment, we see Jesus is God.
We see that played out.
We've, we spent months studying the book of Colossians,
and we remember from Colossians chapter two verses eight
and nine, lemme get over there real quick.
Colossians chapter two verses eight and nine.
It says, see to it that no one takes you captive
by philosophy and empty deceit according to human tradition,
according to the elemental spirits of this world,
not according to Christ.
For in him the fullness of deity dwells bodily.
Now, if there's not a more clear expression of Jesus being,
God, I I, if there's one more I'd love to see it,
but it says, forend him, the fullness
of deity dwells bodily,
and you have been filled in him who is the head
and the rule of all authority, that he is truly God,
and he was truly man in the flesh.
And Titus, uh, we see the good glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ.
And there's actually, um, there's a, there's a, a,
I think it's a Greek rule that comes out of this,
and it's called the Grandville sharps rule.
And this is what I learned while I was sitting in the
airport on Sunday, Monday, couldn't get home,
that the Grandville Sharps rule talks about
that if there are two nouns that are connected, um,
and then, then there's like one adjective then that applies
to both of those things.
It re it re applies to the, the, the same.
So when he says in Titus chapter two, verse 13, uh,
this is a Greek lesson, right?
He says, we're waiting, Titus says that we are waiting
for our blessed hope, the appearing of the glory
of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ.
So he's not saying, we're waiting for the appearing
of our great God, stop and savior Jesus Christ.
He's not saying that you, you can't split it up.
But what he's saying is, we're waiting for the glory
of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ.
And so that it applies that God
and Savior apply to Jesus Christ.
And, and that those all are connected in that, in that rule.
And, um, and so when those two are connected,
it applies to both.
In second Peter chapter one, Peter talks to us, um,
about Jesus, our God and Savior.
And so we see that same rule, um, kind of apply that,
those two things in chapter two,
verse one, I'm sorry.
Um, in second Peter, chapter one verse one, he says, Peter,
a servant apostle of Jesus Christ are those
who obtained faith of equal standing with ours
by the righteousness of our God and Savior Jesus Christ.
So Jesus is both God and Savior. He's proclaiming it again.
Um, in John chapter eight, we see
that Jesus says about himself, before Abraham was, I am.
And he talks about before incarnate time, he was.
And so we see that in Revelations 22.
Again, him declaring himself as the alpha
and the mega, the beginning and the end.
And um, and then John chapter one is, is a passage that,
that stands on its own as the Trinity is revealed,
that the word became flesh.
And clearly we know that to be Christ and dwelt among us,
and that he was with God and he was God.
And so we see that relationship
and it's beautiful then that we see the next step from that.
In, in John's next writing, his first John, first John,
chapter four, we says, God is love.
So we can apply that back in the middle of, of,
um, John chapter one.
Um, so many passages talk about the Holy Spirit.
Uh, I wanna get to some questions.
The Holy Spirit, if is, is a who, right? He's a person.
Uh, we see in, uh, acts chapter five that he can be lied to.
And it's also in that passage
that we see the deity of the Holy Spirit.
It says, you, you lied to the Holy Spirit
and you lied to God.
Those were the two accusations made.
And so those, they're, they're linked together.
Um, we see the Holy Spirit speaking in Acts chapter 13.
And in chapter 10, um,
we read in Ephesians chapter four verse 30,
that we can grieve the Holy Spirit in Hebrews
that we can insult the Holy Spirit.
And then, um, we're, we are called to, um,
baptized in Matthew 28, in the name of Father, son,
and Holy Spirit, right?
It doesn't say the names, but the name of each one.
And so that's, uh, we see those all throughout,
uh, the New Testament.
Um, how are we doing on time?
I wanna leave some time for questions.
So these are seven questions that have been commonly asked,
and I'll go through these pretty quickly
and then we'll open up for your questions.
The first is, why isn't the word trinity found in the Bible?
Okay, so why isn't it the word trinity found in the Bible?
Well, God didn't ordained
to put the word trinity in the Bible,
so it's not in the Bible, but is
that a reason to not believe in it?
And we would say no, because we see evidence of the Father,
son, and spirit working together just as we've studied.
We would also say that we don't see the word omniscient
anywhere in scripture, right?
But we believe in the omniscience of God, right?
We don't see the word omnipresent anywhere in scripture,
but we believe in the omnipresence of God.
And so there are things about God
that the word doesn't exist, but scripture speaks to it.
Second question, how can Jesus be God if he said in John
chapter 17, the God and Father is the only true God.
So Jesus said, chapter John chapter 17, verse three,
the God the Father is the only true God.
And we would say yes, and Jesus is God.
And yes, the Spirit is God.
And in John chapter one, it says, the word was God,
and the word was with, I'm sorry, the word was God.
And the word was with God
that those two are in the same verse, right?
So that's, that's an answer, kind of that question.
Uh, one other question that, the third question
that some people, times people ask is in John chapter 14,
verse 28, where Jesus says, my Father is greater than I.
And so we've addressed that a little bit, where, um,
it's kind of like, it's the sense in which Jesus is saying
that He's saying that in the person, in the place
that he is, that yes God the Father is greater God the
Father, um, is greater in person, uh, at that time
because he, um, he has humbled Christ has humbled himself,
taking on the form of a servant relative to the will of
our triune God in saving humanity.
And so he took on that mantle, he took on flesh and that,
and that God, the Father, is greater than me
because God the Father sent me.
Um, and so we see
that unpacked in Philippians two, like we talked about.
Um, the fourth question was, well,
if Jesus is God, who is he praying to?
Can God pray to God?
And, um, and we would say that yes,
because they interrelate and we see that interrelation
before the world began, that that, that,
that is a problem, right?
If you believe in modalism, so that,
that if you believe in modalism, which is where there,
that God can only exist as the Father or the Son
or the Spirit, then that is a problem.
'cause then you get this situation where Jesus is speaking,
Lord speak, father speaks back,
Jesus speaking, and he switches.
And, and that's not the way it works out, right?
It's this, it's this inner relationship that we know existed
before the world began.
So the fifth question is, how can ge
or sixth question is, um, what about,
and people will say in, um, Colossians chapter one,
verse 15, that Jesus was created, um,
and this is one of the, one of the heresies where there's a,
a manipulation of scripture
and that he's God in human form,
it says He's the firstborn of all creation.
Well, that word firstborn can, it,
it oftentimes means a preeminence.
It identifies not necessarily a, a birth order
so much as a preeminence.
And we see that actually in Exodus four, uh, chapter 22,
where it's used that firstborn is used as a preeminence
where he says that Israel, my firstborn, that
that Israel wasn't the first of many sons, right?
Israel was the chosen people of God.
And so he, Israel had a preeminence because of God's choice.
And so it also goes on to say in cautions
that all things are created in him
and through him that he's not part of the created,
that he was a creator,
and things are created in him and through him.
So the last question is, if Jesus is God,
why didn't he just say it?
And so we would say He did, right?
He said it all throughout the Book of John,
he said it in the Book of Revelations.
In fact, they tried to kill Jesus
because of his proclamation, uh, through his words
that he was God.
And so he did distinguish himself from the Father,
but also did, also identified
himself as one with the Father.
And that's really what got him in so much trouble.
And so, um, as we get to the end of this, I, I hope
that it's a little bit more clear and not less.
I know I've kind of thrown a lot of stuff out there.
I do wanna take some time to ask questions.
So I may ask Aaron to come up while we answer questions,
but if you have questions,
start making your way to the microphone.
And, um, while you're doing so, I'll keep talking
until somebody gets to a microphone.
So if you have a question, go to a microphone. Thank you.
Um, but one of the things he said
in thinking about the Trinity is trying
to connect the trinity, sorry,
I didn't warn Aaron about the fly paper.
Um, that we wanna connect the Trinity back to the gospel.
So look for the father, look for the son, look
for the spirit working in, in the gospel
and how we are saved, right?
That, that the, the father, the son,
the Spirit were president creation.
They created this perfect world.
And then we saw in Genesis three
after the fall that it was identified, he said
that he's become like us.
So that, that we as people become separated
and then how the Father, son Spirit work
together in our redemption.
Uh, that, that that allows us to kind
of even look and dig a little bit deeper. How do
Aye. Uh,
Okay, now you can hear me.
Uh, first I was gonna say thanks for, uh,
the church taking on hard topics.
Uh, it's better
to talk about things even though we don't understand it,
but it's better to talk about than shy away.
Uh, and my question is, it's coming from Matthew 24 36.
Uh, this is where it's talking about the, the second coming
and it says, but concerning that day, our no one knows,
not even the angels of heaven
nor the son, but only the Father.
Uh, and I know that that says in my notes,
it's some trans translations don't have
that part nor the sun.
But just wanted to get your thoughts
and clarifying how we could look at that verse
amongst all the other verses that talk about the trinity.
Good. Um, I think that's a tricky one.
Um, and I think that, um,
there, I think it, it clearly says it, so we have
to take it at its word, um, relative to that.
But we would say, how do we, how do we come
to grips with that, right?
I think is the question that no one can knows the day
or the hour, not even the angels of heaven
nor the son, but the father only.
And so, um, well that's tricky
that, um, there would, there would be is that the,
the son is manifest as Jesus, or that's not even right.
I'm gonna say that wrong way. You say it a better way here.
I'm gonna think for a second if you have a response.
Yeah, that's one of those we don't quite understand.
'cause how can, uh, God, Christ be fully God
and not be able to communicate everything to each other?
Uh, so yeah, that's one of those things we just have
to say we don't know how, that's how that works out.
Um, you know, it's kinda like Jesus grew in favor with God
and man, Luke 2 52, how does that,
how, how does that work out?
Jesus grew in favor with God.
So there's just some things there that we just quite can't,
again, comprehend on our level that we just have to say,
Lord, I, we trust you at your word,
but we don't quite understand how that works out.
That's a, that's a great question.
And I think part of it too is like we, we think
so linearly that we think, we think about a date, right?
We think about October 27th, 2075.
Don't nobody write that down, but like, I just made that up.
But like, we would think of some number out there that
that's the day that, that the Lord's
gonna come back and return.
And that's a limitation of our mind of the flesh.
And that, um,
To say, I'm so sorry.
Yeah, but with Christ being holy man and holy God,
but in some aspect he did have to, he had
to step away from his glory,
but wouldn't have to also kind of going to
that question, I would think he would in some aspect not,
and I don't wanna blast him or, or any of that,
but there would be some limitation to his being able
and being in a physical man body where we have
that limitation because of our flesh.
And it's not necessarily because of simpleness, but it's
because it hasn't yet been revealed to us.
Would that in the same aspect,
because he's fully banned in that, in that present time
where it hasn't, do you?
Yeah. Do you understand where I'm coming from? Would that be
Right?
Yeah. It's, it is, it is super hard to, to kind
of unpack the fullness of what we call the hypostatic union.
That in essence that, that Jesus had fully essence of God.
He never gave up one ounce of his deity,
but yet he took on flesh.
Okay? So it, it, it may be a struggle to say limitation,
but he took on flesh
that he was still a hundred percent God.
He didn't give up or like,
but the, the, the way that was expressed, the way the son,
he was in the flesh for 33 years, right?
And so during that time, he experienced hunger.
He didn't experience hunger any different than I
experienced hunger.
'cause he had a fleshly body,
but yet, um, he still was fully God so that
he was able to work through
that differently, right?
I mean, he could make bread for himself, I guess,
if we wanted to, but he, but he didn't, right?
I mean, so to to back to the question a little bit of
that it wasn't that there are,
he says not the son, but the father only.
And so we have to, we do have to take that at its word.
And then
If Say that there are some,
Excuse me, sorry. Yeah.
Um, I also think some of that is Hebrew wedding,
um, language, if you will,
because the son would go
and get his bride, get betrothed, go back home,
build his brides home.
And when the father said the son was finished,
the son didn't know when the father would say the father
chose the time and date,
and the father would then tell the son, go get your bride.
And it, to me, it's kind of like Hebrew wedding language,
Right? Yeah,
that's, I mean, that's
A good point. And I agree
and I think there's too, there's a,
there's a hierarchy there where,
where Christ is subordinating himself right
At that time To his father in
That position, right?
Absolutely. Right. So yeah, there are, yeah.
'cause there's, and we see the,
the prayer in the garden in different
times where they're relating.
Um, and it's that, um, it's that submission that's
in that perfect relationship.
What's the next question?
So ti just what people are thinking, why does, why does
the study of the Trinity matter?
What, what is the, I think John raised
that question on Sunday, you know, it's one
of our big rocks, but why, why is the Trinity matter?
That's a maybe a question that people may be asking. Yeah,
I think that's good. Why
would we devote a whole week to it?
Well, I think part of it's
because we do see so many false teachings
and heresies come out of it.
And so, and some of them can start from a place that seem
to have some reason, and they come from a place that would,
that would have worldly logic.
And we would say, oh, yeah, three in one that's like a,
an egg or a whatever, different thing.
But yet it takes us off track.
And so if we don't understand
and know the truths of God's word
and what it says relative to the father, son spirit,
and how they, they perfectly are as one essence,
then we can, we can diminish one or the other.
Right? We can. And that steals glory from God.
And so when we can get,
be let off into these false teachings, whether that be
modalism or a, a, a, a creation of,
of Son or the spirit like that,
it really takes away from the glory of who God is.
And so that's, then we're,
then we're off on some rabbit trail.
Right? Um, and,
and it is just one of those things where to know,
to recognize the false teachings,
you really do have to understand the truth.
And because, and you have
to understand when people are twisting scripture
for their own end and their own gain.
So to know about the truth of scripture allows us
to speak truth and when we're, when we're asked about lies.
Thank You. Yeah, go ahead Albert. Okay.
We pray, and we all oftentimes say
that the Trinity's all equal God,
the Father God son, godly Holy Spirit.
But our prayers, we pray to God.
We pray to Jesus, but rarely do we pray to the Holy Spirit.
Are we derelict in doing that? Or is it good or bad?
Yeah. No, I think it's perfectly fine
to pray to the Holy Spirit.
They're all, it's all one,
But we don't, uh, But we don't. Yeah, you're right.
The last time you heard a prayer said, dear Holy Spirit,
Right.
I have heard people say that.
Uh, but even Christ prayed our Father in heaven, right?
When you pray, pray like this, our Father in heaven.
Uh, so he kind
of gave us some instruction there of how to pray.
But I think absolutely you can pray.
It's he's three persons in one.
You can pray all three of those. Absolutely.
Should we, should we intentionally try
to include the Holy Spirit when we address our prayers?
Probably should, Yeah. I think, um, yes.
But I don't know if we grieve him
unless we're consciously doing it.
If we're, if we're saying, I'm not gonna pray the Holy
Spirit, 'cause I don't think he's a person, right?
'cause I think he's just an energy
and I'm, I don't really believe he's God, then
that does, that grieves the Spirit.
That's, that's grieving the Spirit,
that's blaspheming the spirit in some ways.
And so, yes. But if we're saying, God, father,
I'm praying to you in the name of your son Jesus empowered
because of the work or the words that are coming out,
because of the work of your spirit in me.
And we see that modeled in scripture, right.
That the, the Spirit prays
for us when we don't have the words
to say He empowers our prayers that we lift in the name
of the Son to the Father.
It's not wrong, I don't think to, to pray
to any person of the Trinity.
But we would, we would pray to God, right?
We would pray to our trying God
and relate in the different ways, I think,
in which he relates to us.
Thank you. Good question, Albert.
Uh, mine comes from Genesis one,
and you referenced this earlier, tr
but in 1 26, when God said, let us make man in our image
after our likeness,
and let them have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the birds of the heavens from the livestock
and over all the earth and over every creeping thing
that creeps on the earth.
Um, my question is one of those ones, you,
you're talking about kind of
refining our understanding without getting to a,
an absolute is, um, is a worthy pursuit to understand God
and our relationship to him on the topic
of us being image bearers of God
and his, uh, relational nature.
Is that a common grace or, or is it accurate
or dangerous to think of us being relational beings as a one
of the attributes, as image bearers
of God being a relational being within himself?
And is that a common grace to believers and believers alike?
And are there, are there errors or,
or slippery slopes that,
that can go considering it that way?
Does the question make sense? Mm-Hmm.
Yeah. It makes perfect. I think that's a,
that's a great deep question.
Uh, I think, I think in a lot of ways it is.
Um, it's interesting though, if we think about the rest of
that creation narrative, right?
So he made Adam, he made Adam in his likeness,
and then Adam had relationship with God,
but he, he saw that he also needed another person.
Mm-Hmm. I mean, obviously God is sovereign.
He's all knowing. And, and he, he created them perfectly
and then they were in relationship with one another.
Um, and then so we would see the brokenness
of all the interpersonal, all the interrelatedness, well,
Even greatest, greatest commandment, right?
The two, two sides of that kind of same coin of love, God
and others, that, that relational.
So I, I think to answer your question, yes,
that is a common grace that's extended to us as
people made in his likeness, that part of
what makes us in his likeness is the way that we,
or the way that we do, but that we can
and have a desire to relate to one another.
And also that there's something in us that,
that longs for our creator.
Mm-Hmm.
Okay. Thanks. And that desire for a relationship
with him as part of that,
Could I offer, Is everybody over here?
No. Okay. Sorry. Mark.
Could I, I just wanna offer one comment
that I think addresses two of the questions.
You know, one is, um, addressing the question
of should we pray to the Holy Spirit or not?
And then, um, the question
before that, I'm, um, blanking on it,
but the, in John John 14, um,
15 and 16, Jesus says, if you love me,
you'll keep my commandments and I'll ask the Father,
and he will give you another helper to be with you forever,
even the spirit of truth whom the world cannot receive.
So it really addresses the question
of why should we know about the Holy Spirit?
Why should we think about these three persons
that make up the Godhead?
And I think that knowing the correct relationship
of the three helps us when we pray,
and Jesus instructed us to pray in this way.
He instructed us to pray our Father who art in heaven,
that when we pray, we know that we have a helper who's
with us, who is expressing, as Paul says, things
that are sometimes too deep for us to express.
Mm-Hmm. And so if we have that correct understanding,
we know that as we pray with our limited vocabulary
and words and understandings, we know
that Jesus promises us, that the Holy Spirit is
praying, communicating somehow
with the Father on our behalf.
He's expressing things that we don't know how to express
on our behalf, which is another
strange thing for us to think about.
How does, how do our prayers to the Father, uh, need
to be explained or need to be Expressed to the Father?
But Jesus said he does that He labors for us,
and that Jesus is also there at the
right hand of the Father.
It says on our behalf,
as it says in Hebrews four.
Um, so, um, anyway, I just thought as,
as I was thinking about those two questions,
a correct understanding helps us know the relationship,
and then when we pray, we can pray to the Father knowing
that Jesus is hearing it,
and the Holy Spirit's there also laboring on our behalf.
That's a great word. Thank you, mark.
And yes, in John 14 through 17, if you just wanna read
and marvel at the Trinity
and Father sin spirit, working together,
spend time in those chapters.
You got any other good questions? Gosh. Okay.
Pray for, yeah.
Um, yeah, I think we're, we're too a good spot.
We pray for us. So we'll close.
Yeah. Let's pray together. Lord, we are grateful
to have an evening like this where we can, um, talk about
your word and how to, uh,
relate to you by how you have revealed yourself to us.
And so we're grateful, we're grateful
that you didn't leave us here alone without, uh,
any guidance or anything about you.
Thank you for your word
and how you've revealed yourself through the scriptures
and through Christ, through your creation.
We worship you, uh, God and the Father.
We worship God the Son, and we worship God the Spirit.
We are grateful for all three,
but we're grateful for the one.
And, uh, so thank you.
Thank you, Lord, for, uh, the truths of your word.
Thank you for tr and all of his preparation,
and we pray tonight that, uh, you'll bless us as we go and,
and just continue to enlighten us
as we open up your word, St.
Christ. And we pray. Amen. Amen. Thank you all.